guten Morgen
in Berner Oberland wir startet in Dietls
[Musik]
das kleine familienfreundliche Skigebiet
ach du scheibenkleister ich weiß jetzt
muss ich wahrscheinlich
es ist Anfang Januar aber die Skibus ist
es gab ganz Hindernis
1200 Metern
[Musik]
freut mich dankeschön
[Gelächter]
okay also das ist jetzt wirklich mal
Skigebiet von der anderen Seite oder mir
rechnet ja alle damit dass es oder ihre
Autos ist viel Schnee hat vieles
durchgeht viel Leute und ETS sich
einfach tote Hose
3 Tag im Skigebiet grimealp wo man
sehnsüchtig auf der Schnee wartet das
ist Mona mittendrin
[Musik]
spontan
ja jetzt ja ich habe praktisch
[Musik]
Alex und Pamela mächtig
Familienunternehmen
[Musik]
im Gegensatz zu unerb im Kinderskilift
hat
[Musik]
1800 Meter Hecks
das Hotel ist zur
und aus Sportgeschäft vom Alex 400
mit treffend
Alex sind auch dabei
Prozent
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
4 Wochen später
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Mami und Papi hilf mir es selbst zu tun
bis 14:30 Uhr Gruppe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hey ich glaube ich tue da
Skilift traumatisieren
[Musik]
danke vielmals
[Gelächter]
verabschieden
[Musik]
zack zack zack wirklich ich weiß bosnuss
sehr gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
der Wintersportort das bedeutet das
jetzt arbeite für euch Familie ist es
total wichtig aber ganze Familie ist in
der musikgenerationen
irgendwie durcheinander
[Musik]
und das Präparieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so der danke dir später
im älteren Haus von der Pamela findet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du snowly welches
[Musik]
sehr gut
[Applaus]
Wintersport jetzt doch noch gefunden
[Musik]
es dauert schon wieder in Berner
Oberland
und alle Prognosen
[Musik]
iger
[Gelächter]
sehr sehr spannend gut
er Familie für ihre im Jahr
mit Flocken vom Himmel belohnt hättest
da oben Schnee
[Musik]